that girl standing in front of me is  Chloe my dear cousin that's Vivian my  best advisor whenever I needed I leave  the apartment in 98 Humboldt Street to  my brother Dave while the fool on Cherie  I leave to my nieces Chloe mode see  Vivian Parker modes 50%  Paul Russell I work for United East  Coast bank the bank that has been  supporting this business but is now then  stopped supporting it because its owner  just different  show some respect it smells dead why are  you wearing that I thought we agreed you  were going to Europe and I was running  the villagers Oh Chloe  this is crazy welcome to my 50% what is  going on in here I want that place on  the market buddy a minimum we have a lot  to do and not a lot of time leave me I'm  gonna do whatever I can to help you I  can't go to universe he's the enemy keep  your friends close and your enemies  closer  Lane because I could be neither on the  situation  I'm just trying to keep my promise tears  about  [Music]  you  you